keep talking [__] about our accent keep
talking [__] about our accent the worst
accent yo haters cuz they don't have our
[__] accent you saw they said about
you hear this they talk about the women
now hold up hold up hold up you just
made a lot of sense can you can you
explain what's going on right now they
saying the ugliest accent is the New
York accent but they're talking about
the women with the New York accent and
can we just can we just keep it a buck
can we just keep it a buck and be like
dayri
right yo New York women cut that [__]
out you know stop trying to talk like us
T Toronto girls with the Toronto accent
one girl you saw that it made me sick to
my stomach made me sick you leave your
mom's in the snow fam that makes me sick
that makes me sick got to waste these UT
fam that [__] was hard I know you got to
bring that [__] up I was dying that's
the Drake influence though that is Drake
I mean you did a joke about this but
like Drake changed the way Canadians
talk it's true that's wild it is true
they whatever influence Drake got here
10x in Canada 100% he runs Canon that's
prime minister no one hears talking like
that like no you hear people be like oh
Ting you know oh that's sliding in
there's a couple thingss at the club
that's what toboy made me
realize not no no no hold on hold on
this is the crazy thing it comes from
British
slang but Drake is the reason why it's
being used here so he didn't start it
but he influence it yall giving this
[__] too much CRA it's Kim Kardashian
with cornrow no way no way I feel like
I'm telling you it's has more [__]
influence than Drake in terms I see it
like you walk down Soho there's a bunch
of asaps walking around I'm just saying
I just
fly so yeah in terms of Lang today
wasn't the
day today was a light today wasn't a
light one light I mean you still put
together but it's not ASAP you can't be
like he influenced me I I know I know
yeah you look like you go to Yale stop
it bro right now it's a compliment it's
an IDE school only you would be upset
you look smart and educ educated [__]
you sorry what do you think an
understudy
is that's an acting term for the guy
that's going to take your role that
would be your ta that's what the [__] I
you Dum [__] you don't even know
the
[__] you don't look like you bro you
know I take that back immediately okay
bring this bring
this I don't like cuz if the business is
true that you left your mom's in the
hood somebody go smoke that you you
don't leave your mom's nowhere you have
money and you left your mom's there yo
you're sick to my stomach fam but if
it's not true is just [__] [__] y
you're sick to my stomach F bro that's
got to be the worst accent right for a
girl to have no no New York is still
worse really you never heard a girl say
suck my dick in a New York accent
obviously that's com y'all never had if
you get Brooklyn like a real Brooklyn
girl or Bron I don't even know how they
have sex with them girls
suck my dick no you suck my
dick suck my dick from the back yo it's
too much bro I'm telling you the New
York female accent when they really lean
in yeah like an Italian girl from
Brooklyn is crazy do they do they do
that in bed still you think yes that's
how they still talk even while they're
[__] still yeah you know the area in
Brooklyn bed still no is that how they
talk while you're in bed like still like
do they keep the accent while they're
[__] look at you whack bars like
Drake right now your hand on your man
what I'm this album was light what did
you want from it I just want more
rapping like it was just too slow the
whole album is rapping no it's not it's
like a [__] R&B album for the most
part that's also fire so it's just not
for me I'm it's not a bad album It's
just Alex gets engaged he's like I hate
this soft [__] you know what I mean
that's what
happens toxic CH that's what I'm saying
bro go 10 years ago like New York you
used to be a dog bro this album used to
be for he used to be a real dog [__]
doodle not a dog anymore that sucked man
Doodle's a dog [__]
[__] Point C he's got a point got you
got me you got me that's a good point
okay what's worst accent what's best
accent for dudes obviously New York is
the best accent for dud no dude no well
what is it n you got to give it to the
Brits no I wouldn't say to the what the
Brits no say in America in America in
America I was singing Brits best accent
for dudes in America's New York
accent country twang oh country but
you're not listening to that [__] all
day like what if you need directions
from somewhere and there's some
[__] with a goddamn yeah yeah
like a corn cob pipe and he's just well
make a r byy the water meal that [__]
sounds fire actually that sh act like it
be honest that just
sound it's pretty
good like a new
yor most people with that accent don't
give out
Direction you want some directions get
the [__] out of here huh
but they say it you just go up on that
tree put your
name yeah I don't know about a southern
but which Southern cuz there's some real
Hew Southern Accents that I don't think
you're going to like the Appalachian
Mountain [__] with the banjo I don't
think number one you want like a swaave
like a North Carolina like a Nashville
South Carolina Nashville probably
probably be good you want something with
Elegance something with a
plantation oh W no don't say that but
not they don't still make it work but
what they don't still now it's just a
home it's just a home that was once a
plantation yeah what is that now you
want like a Savannah Georgia masses same
drawn out yes
yeah was
funny VA had to get the mic to be gay
that's he told me to take the
M what's your favorite accent muslim's
getting confident dude let's go baby uh
valley girl what valley girl accent
really oh my God on women on women I
hate it on
women bro on men it's not as
cool you like the valley girl Accent on
men that's that's your favorite okay wa
your favorite female accent is valley
girl yeah are you being dead serious
with this H I would do New York over
Valley they're just hot a girl with valy
girl accent's hot it hurts my ears for
real do you like dumb girls yeah
so why are you so in a Mark's sister
what's the whole explain that oh my can
we talk about that